maintenir le dialogue malgré les
divergences étaient le modus operandi de
la chancelière allemande angela merkel
dans ses relations avec la russie et
même si nous avons de profondes
divergences aujourd'hui nous nous
parlons il faut que cela continue afin
de mettre de l'ordre dans les relations
germano russes et les perfectionner lors
de son dernier tête à tête en forme
d'adieu avec alain moscou vladimir
poutine a reconnu que c'était en partie
grâce à google à merkel que l'allemagne
était considéré comme un des partenaire
clé de la russie je tiens à souligner
que la république fédérale d'allemagne
reste l'un de nos principaux partenaires
tant en europe que dans le monde en
général j ce notamment grâce aux efforts
que vous avez déployés au cours des 16
dernières années en tant que chancelière
fédérale des diligences et des crises il
y en a eu pas mal durant les six années
de marquer le pouvoir des accusations
d'ingérence dans les élections
allemandes ou de cyber espionnage sans
oublier la sphère navalni qui malgré sa
résonance extrême n'a pas ébranlé la
construction du gazoduc nord stream 2
décidément projet unique que ni
l'administration de trope ni
l'administration baden n'ont su faire
capoter
je crois qu'à berlin il savait et savent
très bien que les relations avec la
russie sont d'une importance
fondamentale et si l'allemagne s'étaient
pliés dans cette situation avec nord
stream 2 en autorisant une ingérence
dans les accords économiques bilatéraux
sous l'influencé de l'intervention d'un
pays tiers alors elle aurait démontré sa
faiblesse devant son propre peuple et ça
ne va pas c'est la première chose
deuxièmement nous savons que pour le
secteur industriel allemand uhde champ
du feu dont les dépenses énergétiques
sont déjà les plus élevés parmi les pays
occidentaux la sécurité énergétique des
sources d'approvisionnement est au moins
primordiale car son avenir en dépend en
principe
avec les élections des stades les
relations russo allemandes risquent de
prendre un tour nouveau
trois candidats sont donnés favoris pour
remplacer angela merkel au poste de
chancelière la candidate des verts anna
lena bareback c'est non seulement
prononcé contre le projet nord stream 2
au point d'un visage y renoncer mais a
aussi promis de durcir le ton dans ses
relations avec moscou ce gazoduc
contredit les intérêts géostratégiques
des européens il est clairement dirigé
contre l'ukraine il entre en
contradiction avec les objectifs
climatiques européen et toutes les
sanctions de l'union européenne contre
la russie c'est donc un projet
absolument nuisibles de son côté le
candidat de l'union
chrétien-démocrate armes ils l'achètent
que le journal süddeutsche zeitung a
qualifié de celui qui comprend poutine
d'air poutine cherche terre a déclaré
que l'allemagne pour été arrêtés
d'acheminer du gaz russe via north
stream 2 si moscou ne respectait pas les
conditions de l'accord ou l'utiliser
pour faire pression sur l'ukraine pas
évident dans le contexte actuel de
risque de pénurie d'hydrocarbures en
europe même dans la plus froide des
guerre froide il ya toujours eu des
échanges économiques et un dialogue
entre les sociétés civiles cela doit
être notre principe tout en exhortant au
respect des droits humains
le troisième candidat en lice shot
membre du parti social démocrate qui se
positionne comme l'héritier de merkel
mise sur un dialogue avec moscou même
s'il a dénoncé le rattachement de la
crimée à la russie en 2014 critiquer la
situation autour des droits de l'homme
dans le pays où l'empoisonnement présumé
de l'opposant alexeï navalni je soutiens
l'idée selon laquelle la russie et
d'autres pays doivent accepter la
poursuite de l'intégration européenne
nous ne voulons pas revenir à la
politique des 17ème 18ème et 19ème
siècle lorsque les grandes puissances
mondiales russie allemagne france
angleterre faisait de la politique les
uns avec les autres si nous voulons
assurer la sécurité commune en europe
l'union européenne et la russie
devraient s'y engager
une page se tourne donc dans les
relations russo allemandes avec le
départ d'angola merkel reste à savoir
quelle sera la tonalité que le nouveau
chancelier ou la nouvelle chancelière
donnera au prochain chapitre